the mummy is a hugely underrated
adventure movie but that doesn't mean
it's perfect what happened to imitep's
final plague whose idea was that curse
and what's with those egyptian side
characters we have questions
from a contemporary vantage point it's
hard to watch the mummy without noticing
that the movie is very much haunted by
the specter of colonialism in fact the
plot literally wouldn't advance if the
english and american characters didn't
reflexively feel that it was their right
to go to egypt and do basically whatever
they wanted evie and jonathan are
reportedly part egyptian via their
mother but they're played by white
english actors using english accents and
clearly read as essentially english like
many characters in the franchise they
see the riches of egyptian civilization
as both a thing of the past and entirely
up for grabs imitab's rise acts partly
as a commentary on all that when you
blunder into a culture and history you
don't fully understand you can unleash
more than you intend to
no
you must not read from the book you can
also see the lingering presence of
empire in the histories of rick and
winston the former first comes across
haminoptra when he's serving in the
french foreign legion and the latter is
a former british officer hanging around
in egypt because he misses the daring
battles of his glory days egypt isn't
quite home in the mummy it's a place
where you're supposed to have colorful
dangerous adventures that take you out
of your ordinary life and for just about
all the white characters egypt mostly
exists as a playground one in which you
can make your name and find a fortune
it sure is nice that the magi dedicate
their lives to making sure imitep
doesn't rise from the dead but all of
this could have been avoided if their
ancient predecessors simply hadn't used
the dreaded hom die curse in the first
place imitep's priests were mummified
alive isn't that punishment enough for
the man himself did someone really need
to include flesh-eating scarabs and
magical incantations to make imitep's
death just a little bit worse than it
would be already when the consequences
could be so dire if you have two means
of slow gruesome and painful execution
to choose from it seems that you should
always choose the one that can't
potentially backfire and give your enemy
immortality invincibility and the chance
to destroy the world why risk it for one
more twist of the knife the mummy
features several well-written and
prominent egyptian characters artist bae
is skilled charismatic mysterious and
even surprisingly funny meanwhile imitep
is a compelling well-motivated villain
with terrific screen presence even dr
terence bay the museum curator and
evie's beleaguered supervisor has some
great scenes but it's hard to avoid the
fact that a lot of the other egyptian
characters are basically jokes and those
jokes often have a nasty racial
component the warden is an undesirable
travel companion who acts as a constant
butt of the movie's humor it's
particularly uncomfortable that jonathan
keeps saying that he smells bad even his
death by flesh eating scarabs which
sounds horrific in theory it's like a
comedic beat
when imitep's return to life and power
seemingly convinces most of cairo to go
along with him their mass mumbled
chanting and lifeless shambling seem
like a visual gang they're essentially
zombies it's great that the movie boasts
some bold interesting characters of
color it's just unfortunate that many of
the supporting characters fall into some
pretty ugly stereotypes
nobody should quibble too much about the
technical details in a film that
includes mummies resurrection spells and
ancient curses still you may find
yourself asking is the map to hemanoptra
really going to remain intact after more
than 3 000 years actually it turns out
that this isn't as unlikely as it may
seem thousands of pieces of ancient
egyptian papyrus have survived into the
modern day thanks to the arid egyptian
weather while the paper might decay
quickly and more humid environments it's
much safer in the desert but if you've
raised your eyebrows at that pristine
map in the mummy your suspicions weren't
completely unfounded as there's a little
bit of hollywood cleanup going on here
papyrus documents from as far back as 4
500 years ago have survived into the
present day but it's fair to say that
they don't tend to be in sparkling
condition
uncharacteristically when imitep takes
poor mr burns's eyes the mummy misses
the chance for a great if cruel gag burn
says early on that without glasses he
couldn't even see well enough to play
cards and when his glasses are broken in
the mad scramble after imitep rises it
becomes clear that he wasn't
exaggerating his view of the world is a
blurry mess of course burns vision is
about to get even worse as immitep tears
out his eyes and tongue to replace his
own kickstarting his journey back to
life the film only shows the aftermath
but it's surprisingly harrowing it also
inevitably raises a big question if
imitep took burns's eyes shouldn't he
have burns terrible swimmy vision a
cursed mummy who's barely able to see
his own crumbling hand in front of his
decaying face is exactly the kind of
comedic beat the mummy could pull off so
it feels like a shame to miss it the
best the audience gets is a hint as when
imitep is getting used to his new eyes
he squints slightly at eevee which feels
like a nod to burns's poor eyesight but
it's not exactly the payoff that the
earlier setup deserved
what makes imitep evil
from a modern day standpoint it's hard
to condemn the fact that he slept with
the pharaoh's mistress imitep and
anuksunamun were genuinely and
passionately in love while the pharaoh
seemed to only treat her as property
even though it's almost always a bad
idea to dabble in resurrection magic
imitap's initial quest to bring anuksunu
moon back to life feels like a grand
romantic tragedy not the beginning of
descent into super villainy when he
comes back from the dead however he
becomes a literal monster imitable seems
to take pleasure in causing fear and
suffering and his ultimate plan is to
take control of the entire world so why
the change answer the hom die the curse
that was inflicted on him didn't just
give him the potential for super-powered
resurrection it faded him to bring about
death and even all the plagues of egypt
in essence the hom died doomed the world
partly by taking away imitep's free will
chalk that up as another win for the
magi
the mummy is a real delight of a movie
but part of what makes it so enjoyable
is that it never really dwells on any of
the carnage that takes place along the
way that serves the movie's tone well
but after a certain number of re-watches
it's hard not to notice how blind the
protagonists can be about all that death
and destruction
americans
when the warden dies a truly horrific
death they're not shaken so much as
confused within minutes jonathan is
cracking a joke at his expense within an
hour or two rick and evie are having a
flirtatious interlude by the fire the
sam apathy is clear when the american
expedition team starts dying off too at
this point the heroes have interacted
with these people a fair amount both on
and off screen and you might expect them
to feel something about their deaths or
you might think they would feel at least
some guilt at having inadvertently
kick-started imitep's devastating reign
of terror in both cases not so much
how long does someone have to be dead
before it's okay to rob their grave this
may be an awkward question to bring up
at a dinner party but it's also
something to think about while watching
the mummy after all the protagonists
kick off the action by infiltrating a
notoriously forbidden gravesite and
excavating a corpse some of them are
hoping for treasure while others are
just hoping for knowledge but all of
them are trespassing on a sacred
cultural site and disturbing a grave is
that really the proper heroic thing to
be doing honestly the outcome of events
in the mummy suggests that it's probably
not yes the lead characters eventually
escape healthy whole and in possession
of plenty of treasure and sequel
potential but look at what they had to
go through to achieve that happy ending
and look at how many of their fellow
grave robbers got lost along the way
the hom die guaranteed imitep the power
to summon the plagues of egypt and even
before his death he was skilled in the
art of resurrection and those
life-sucking abilities also seem closely
tied to the original curse but where did
the sandstorms come from i love the
whole sand wall trick it was beautifully
bastard when winston is flying rick
ardith bay and jonathan and to try to
rescue evie imitep does some impressive
glowering and conjures up a massive
storm to try to knock the plane out of
the air it's sort of a callback to
something that happens when rick first
came across hemanuptra he witnesses
random bursts of sand flying into the
air and eventually it all seems to form
a giant despairing face it's a great
visual but if you stop to think about it
you might find yourself asking why is
immitep a master of the sand and why can
he control it when he's still
technically dead he can also turn into
sand pouring through a keyhole and even
whisking himself away in a sudden flurry
of wind again it's a cool effect but
where does it actually come from
the prophecy predicts that a resurrected
hemitap will bring the return of the ten
plagues of egypt most of them hit
quickly all the water turns to blood
flies and frogs swarm boils strike most
of the population and an eclipse plots
out the sun most of this takes place on
screen and it's fair to assume that more
is happening elsewhere but this plague
progression still leaves the viewer with
some unanswered questions for starters
why doesn't the main cast get affected
by them evie and jonathan are both half
egyptian and in the mummy returns it's
revealed that rick is actually descended
from the magi all of them have
apparently lived there for years
shouldn't they have at least a few boils
on them but the biggest issue is with
the tenth plague the death of the
firstborn sons the movie never mentions
this one even though it could have
provided some amped up third act stakes
what if they had to race to stop imitep
partly to keep this plague from
devastating egypt and potentially
killing jonathan the source of the
movie's comedic relief instead it just
never comes up making for something of
an odd plot hole
the 1932 boris karloff version of the
mummy was an out and out horror movie
and some of its chills remain in the
1999 update this mummy leans more
towards old-fashioned adventure than
horror but it doesn't hesitate to
incorporate more than a few skin
crawling scenes and some of them are
very dark indeed for one thing if you
have a fear of being buried alive the
prologue is a genuinely torturous
experience seeing imitep and his priests
mummified and sealed into their coffins
is bad enough and the cruel cherry on
top is the later revelation that imitep
stayed conscious long enough to scratch
a message into the inside of his coffin
then there are the scarabs themselves
giant bugs that immediately burrow under
your skin
nobody loves that but the most wrenching
scene might be the sad fate of mr burns
imitep's first victim as if it's not bad
enough that the poor guy loses his eyes
and tongue he then has to unknowingly
entertain his attacker with bandaged
eyes and awkward speech he's clumsy
traumatized and overwhelmingly grateful
for some company and kindness when benny
reveals that prince imitab is actually
there to finish the job you started
burns's terror is devastating and makes
for a monster moment worthy of the
original movie check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]